okay we're going to move now into
teachmeet presentation style where we're
going to have I think it's 11
presenters showing us some teacher at
least they'll either present for 2
minutes for 7 minutes
I left mind if they finish sooner maybe
down the practice going to place on time
favorite streets until them and that is
the beach I have to stop you can see
from the program who they are because I
don't want to go through and spend time
with all the introductions and where
they're from but can I just draw your
attention to the list you'll notice that
some of the people who are going to
present are actually pre-service
teachers so we have a mixture of
experienced teachers and pre-service
teachers I know some of those people are
not down in the front anyone elses we're
representing in this session probably
will be better
now because we're going to have to have
very quick change over between these
sessions we can't afford to spend a lot
of time British changing so I just
encourage those people just sort of move
forward rather I see somewhere